what makes a great actor I think a great
actor is someone who can feel as they
listen because a lot of the best moments
I think happen when you're not talking
your response to another person is
something that can feed them in a way
that just having your line when it's
your turn to speak doesn't you know you
can I can see it happened I've been on
both sides of the giving and the
receiving of that where you have your
moment and what I do just what my
response do you what my eyes say what my
body says is I can see the other person
going deeper into what it is that they
want to say because they were they know
that they are being heard and it is a
natural kind of symbiotic thing a
wonderful quote from either Julie Harris
of fantastic actress or Helen Hayes and
other fantastic actress was this she
there was a see she was doing a play on
Broadway and she had to do it night
after night after night for months and
months and months and there is a scene
in which she comes downstage and sits on
a park bench and has a moment and weeps
and someone came up to and they're
talking about the scene and what she's
thinking and all that and the person
says to her the interviewer says how can
you cry every night and she says how can
you not because and that was the end of
the quote was how can you not but
because she was in that moment she was
feeling that feeling she was hearing
those words or feeling that feeling and
how can you not respond to that if
you're really hearing so that's what I
think makes a wonderful actor is being
able to hear and feel
whether you're talking or not and so
being so dialed in to being able to hear
something with a fresh perspective or
this you know night after night to take
you to that place but then also
developing the tough skin to not let
other things that are in the business
bring you down that sounds like an
incredible balance ah therein is the rub
yes yes it is it's not an easy thing we
do you know it's it's challenging on so
many levels because so many other people
you have a job you have that job you go
to that job you do that job you know
we're all this is one of the reasons why
the economic downturn affected me not at
all because you know actors are always
looking for jobs oh so it's not oh my
god I lost my job and because we're
always going from one to another but yes
you have you have to you do have to
balance that but you have to protect
yourself from the slings and arrows of
this silly business of this capricious
business in order to protect your soft
creamy Center for when you actually need
it it's a great analogy
you